- All right, everybody.
This hour is almost up,
but I wanna share one
last gem on social media
that you may have missed.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
I know a lot of grownups
who reward themselves
with a caramel macchiato
or a java chip frap from time to time,
but it's not just grownups obsessed
with such fancy and fun drinks.
Kids are all about it as well.
And that's why a Pittsburgh teacher
used her third grader's
love of one coffee chain
as a reward in the classroom.
No, she did not just
completely dope them up
and pump them up full of caffeine.
She put on a Starbucks incentive day,
transforming the classroom
into a coffee house
while slyly dropping
lessons into the recipe.
We have her on the line right now.
Everybody say hello to Taylor
watching on WTAE Channel 4.
What's up, Taylor?
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Hi, Kelly.
How are you?
- First of all, thank you
so much for being a teacher.
We love you for that.
(Kelly and audience clapping)
- Thanks for having me.
Thank you, that's amazing.
- Incredible,
incredible vocation.
So, explain the incentive day.
- Sure.
So, almost every month I have some sort
of positive behavior incentive
for my third graders.
I've done things like a
beach day, a camping day.
Now, my class this year,
because they're huge fans,
they actually asked me
for the Starbucks day.
And I said once they had
15 days of great behavior,
we would have this.
Now, I think just in about
15 days, they earned it.
So, of course, I had to go all out.
I decorated our entire classroom
with the green tablecloths.
I had actual coffee cups
and treat bags for them.
I myself wore a green apron.
I played coffee house jazz
music throughout the day.
And, of course, had to sprinkle in
a few educational components.
So, some examples.
We corrected the spelling
and grammatical errors
in a fictional menu,
and we did some math by making
change with fictional orders.
However, their favorite part,
as well as my favorite part,
were our coffee breaks throughout the day.
Now, I didn't have actual
coffee served to them.
I did have chocolate milk,
but just like at the actual
Starbucks, they came up,
I wrote their name on their cup.
I took their order with the
whipped creams and syrups
and called their names
and it was just a blast.
- Very cool, man.
Thank you so much for being
such an incredible teacher
and also for joining us today.
(audience clapping)
I'm liking your post right
now, Taylor, all right.
- [Taylor] Thank you.
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate incredible
teachers just like you,
so they're giving the Hempfield
Area School District $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping)
- Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much Taylor.
Have such a blessed day.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Jenna Bush Hager, Barbara
Bush, Cailee Spaeny,
Tiffany, and Daniel Carter.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.